[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's gonna be a lawsuit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know all
it's gonna be
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
oh
that's the reinstalter uh green room
that was long that's the green room
draw your own conclusions you get a
homeless i can hear my headphones
i think i need new headphones my
headphones here are actually a headphone
sponsor all right glad to be yes we're
doing sponsor watch i'm going to come in
with beats
nice
he's a billionaire dr dre beats yeah
that's what he slept i didn't know chris
brown did headphones
right
well that's and that was a mirrored uh
headphone line from rihanna called bruce
uh guaranteed not to fall off in a
beating it's got a lot of bass
all right so we're starting a little
late today because there's been some
breaking news some developments here
with spotify in the joe rogan situation
before i move on to anything
my question to you is
what do you think about the joe rogan
spotify situation
and the apology is it caving do you
think that there's i think he's
absolutely sincere but do you even think
that if someone is sincerely apologetic
that
this is how you handle it of course i
think you know where we line up we've
been in this exact situation before we
talk about that we'll be talking about
gofundme the communists uh gofundme what
they've been doing here to try and stop
the canadian freedom trucker convoy
there's a lot to get to there is a lot
to get to it's a busy week and as you
know halfway i will not be here
wednesday dave landau will be filling in
uh crawdaddy will be in third chair
because of some things with the half
asian kraken that's all uh all i can
talk about but by the way live show
monday through thursday that's the best
way you can tune in you can hit the
subscription all that notification bell
but the best thing is tune in monday
through thursday it's at 10 a.m eastern
considering moving it a little later
because some people have asked us to but
right now it's 10 a.m eastern and if
we're not here you can watch on rumble
you can watch on mug club unless we tell
you that we are not here
we're still streaming live there you go
you got that going on okay perfect
uh all right
before we move on i just we gotta get
right into it gerald as here how are you
i am well a little pissed this weekend
was full of news that i didn't like
right so we'll be getting to that how
are you i'm okay you know what for the
first time i i just i slept in this
morning and by that i mean it's like 6
45 which
we did it again did you forget how
you have it
plugs into a wall still is that is that
your excuse i have an internal clock ah
usually but then i hit that must i must
hit the snooze uh
so i'm okay and uh you know him you love
him actually i will be uh doing some
shows with him touring with him he's
taping his special at the majestic this
saturday don't ask for no more tickets
there are two shows sold out but uh i
will be with him march 26th in
evansville indiana april 16th royal oak
michigan you can see all the dates at
loudworthcrider.com tour those are
almost sold out we might be adding some
shows this week dave landau how are you
sir ahoy good how about you
wait he already asked oh never mind yeah
he wanted to i don't know i said the
whole slept in thing yeah your
biological clock mine's ticking
your biological clock our marriage yes
mine is is there anything else i missed
my is there any more [ __ ] that i could
pile on top of this
is it possible
that movie reference you guys can
comment oh that's easy come on
um
okay so before we move on to everything
else and you must be excited taping your
special this week i actually am yeah i'm
really i'm uh yeah at the majestic in
dallas that's a that's a historical
theater gorgeous gorgeous theater i'm
really excited i think it's like 1800
seats and it just sold out we added a
show so thank you guys this is what this
is what makes this program uncancelable
we'll be talking all this with rogan but
you know we're not employees to anybody
i
run this i've always owned this we have
great partnerships and we are funded by
actual viewers like you uh
lightworkcredit.com slash mug club club
99 annually 69 for students veterans
active military and we take your chats
we do an extra full hour of show every
day okay let's move on sorry go ahead no
no i'm just saying i'm just glad
somebody worked very hard on the
architecture of such a wonderful
building so i could tell penis jokes yes
ah yes exactly because
blueprints also by the way i didn't tell
you we have a couple of hecklers in the
wings but oh who writes these horrible
jokes
my heart hurts
that's just me
uh
i'd rather be home staving off death
now uh this uh lotus stop walking
through the show map here i can see a
little cursor this is a weird monday uh
this video has been making the rounds uh
this morning showing catholics in poland
uh defending the
they have the gaul if you will to defend
the nuclear family as we know black
lives matter refers to it um
in need of destruction how many pollocks
does that take oh geez well you know
what i tell you what the pollock jokes
are done because they're now like we
okay we see how this ends no more yes
oh yeah you want to open borders okay
good luck no we do not any name that is
shaka makalada you're not welcome in
poland i think you understand why we
protect our women okay
it's not that we are racist it's that we
don't want you to rape six-year-old
girls so you stay on that side of line
we have line here in poland we've been
through this before
no more
they have a backbone phenomenal accent
for polish people oh yes yes stupid
pollock joke that's right huh
how many border crossings you have this
week shut up
it's just the kazakh heckler yeah um so
catholics and poland defending the
nuclear family they're being harassed by
lgbt you know what i'm just going to say
uh gay
umbrella i'm not going down that line of
lgbtqaip i'm not going to be it's too
long someone will put together a
highlight reel in 10 years like the
equivalent of me saying the n word
because i didn't include the q-a-a-i-p i
don't care i don't apologize here's some
pollocks defending traditions from these
angry gay activists
[Music]
i thought those are dogs they're barking
well huh oh in a manner of
oh wow
your moms must be so proud
yes this is great pr for you we hold
flag and you look like freaks
thank you for making our point you look
like street urchins from a glow-stick
joel schumacher batman scene good for
you
[Laughter]
you get free tote bag with barking yes i
don't understand the barking where did
that come from
this woman barks like a [ __ ] i can say
it because she is barking like a [ __ ]
uh it's because they're stupid yes ah
yes okay well
thank you for clarifying my preferred
pronouns for you are screw in you how
about that how about go screw and
yourself she
hit
what is this
how do you think that's being effective
like i know i know we'll bark like dogs
that will get them no we're gonna dress
up like halloween and then go bark at
them like dogs and make every point
they're trying to make you know there's
one guy that's like finally a barking
bagpipe band yes
i've been waiting for it forever oh wait
this isn't that first cold take what
gosh imagine being that scot going into
battle who had to play the bagpipes you
know they're taking you out first oh
yeah by your own soldiers
you're breaking the rules of engagement
yes but we have a person with drum and
trumpet and you have sound like dying
cattle so we shoot first
you just sit there nervously going out
there in the front lines like then
you're sure they won't shoot me right
they seem getting madder
no no you're fine you're fine you're
fine
keep going
it seems weird that you actually put a
target on my chest
it's part of the uniform it's a wee bit
further they're just barking out there
the lgbt can you see your q p
all right as we continue with
international politics and we'll tie
this into the fact that the united
states government wants you to just take
their word for everything they are the
experts on medicine they are the experts
on what will be a false flag they are
the experts on what should and should
not be allowed on spotify they are the
experts on who and who should not be d
platformed uh so before we get that uh
saturday night live of course did more
bidding from the government i'm laughing
already
are we sure i really like it when
kathryn mckinnon does that smile
every time
every time
oh
whoever does their casting so uh snl
recently did the sketch about the
russian disinformation uh about the
ukraine how long do how much of this do
we have to watch
i don't know all right by the way as
before i talk about this there's uh a
couple of angry people on cnn right now
saying u.s officials warn russia could
invade ukraine any day here's the thing
the ukraine officials say that's that's
[ __ ] so not so much we'll get to
that but this is you see right you see
synergistically them operating all the
media the government and then of course
snl and here's the question how do all
of them get it wrong
how do all of them get it wrong together
what are the chances of cnn abc nbc cbs
jen saki former vice president joe biden
and snl getting this wrong did they have
a meeting and say do they have a meeting
behind our back and say let's just screw
everything up so yes here's the snl
sketch
russian disinformation with you mr
president
mr president the situation in ukraine is
growing tension by the hour putin has
amassed over 100 000 troops at the
border
we're even getting some reports that
russia has already invaded but those are
from the same people who said tom brady
retired so take it with a grain of salt
you know what about the nato forces are
they ready to back us up
he sounds more like george bush than but
ukraine except germany they're staying
out of it oh man
germany doesn't want to go to war you
know it's bad
sir
russia's military presence may be the
least of our problems
we've been tracking the spread of
russian disinformation in ukraine and
there are some lies ukrainians don't
know what to believe anymore russia
tried that during our last election too
but it didn't work
well 40 of americans think you lost the
election so it kind of did
you see george sees scott look at these
posts that are circulating on ukrainian
facebook
is she kamala ukrainian border
encroaching on russia
she's not indian
russian forces surrounding ukraine just
to give it big hug
ukrainian president horny for drama
wants war slap me harder dandy
the new year's resolution is saying
malarkey
they're also bringing our country into
it why is he doing bush junior i don't
know why he's doing bush jr and the
thing is it's not accurate it's not the
reason that george bush impression was
funny was because there was some truth
the truth would be you know if he had
like a if he had a shark stain halfway
up his back right now and he didn't know
where he was but they can't do that in
snl because you know their buddies their
drinking buddies yeah in real life he
would have had eight strokes already yes
spelled the worst way
i'm a junior at a vicious girls high
school and y'all work for me now let's
just do something fun and simple that
everyone can get behind like a drone
strike kslsnl okay okay mr president i
think your generation can learn a lot
from mine like we don't believe in drone
strikes we believe in breaking down our
enemies psychologically
you've been doing it for years so now
yes
yeah yeah that's how they got khalid
sheikh mohammed to talk they're saying
all right we're gonna put on seasons 19
through 24 of snl no no
the in the children's school okay i give
i don't understand what i just saw i
don't understand it either this is the
problem with look
and whether we understand it or not you
have to acknowledge that it's a joke
it's comedy okay fine no however they're
just
there does need to be a kernel of truth
to it to be funny
right for the same reason that people
are outraged over some of the comments
that joe rogan has made there's a kernel
of truth to the things that he says and
it offends people it upsets people
this doesn't make you can't parody joe
biden and not acknowledge what the vast
majority of americans know that he's not
in his right mind absolutely well the
biggest laugh that they got was at the
very beginning when the general said mr
president and everybody's like that's
part of the joke right they must be some
of that 40 who are victims of exactly
russian disinformation campaign
yes no that's why americans think that
the uh the most free fair secure
election of all time uh might have had
some foul play because they spent 13
grand on facebook ads the ruskies that's
what it is it's like red dawn with
laptops that's what happened yeah okay
slap me harder daddy wouldn't have been
a reverend in 1975 when the show came
out right i know i mean that's bad it's
pushing the limits there are you they're
gonna be really
carol burnett and then have someone or
someone else come out from laughing suck
it to me
[Laughter]
so this is all despite the fact you know
talking about russian disinformation
that ukrainian president
or as uh you know he's labeled an
unauthoritative source by twitter
youtube and uh president zielinski
accused the west of causing quote panic
over russian invasion said the threat
was real but not imminent as the u.s has
explained
in a
comment that he made a source close to
zielinski also equipped quite frankly
these americans are safer in kiev than
they are in los angeles or any other
crime ridden city in the united states
oh wow no he's not wrong that seems to
be pushing back kind of hard yes have
you been to l.a what did we do to
deserve that yes no this is kiev oh no
it's you know it's no skid row but uh i
hear that jimmy fox plays mean violin so
trade-off he's very good
for crying out loud and uh so last week
to talking about russian disinformation
this is what what you know snl has gone
along with and of course this is what
all of big tech has gone along with
we're going to talk about gofundme
what's happening with canada this is
when people say it's not censorship
unless the government
is silencing you
that's not true anymore when the
government is saying we want big tech to
eliminate these voices or we want big
tech to mislabel these voices or or
label them as disinformation when they
are calling out and having meetings with
these people they are acting as an arm
they are acting as thugs for the
government this is unprecedented this is
no longer a libertarian argument if
private business can do whatever they
want because they are beholden not only
to people in our government but foreign
governments like you see what happened
with gofundme shutting down a protest
where zero acts of violence have ever
been committed by the way right now not
three billion dollars in damages like
black lives matter none of that not not
like dozens and actually hundreds of
felonies and thousands of casualties
that had taken place or sorry hundreds
of casualties and many thousands of
felonies who i mix that up don't wanna
be mislabeled this information because
i'm going off the cuff here um
this is an entirely peaceful protest and
gofundme decided they were going to take
steal their money
we'll get to it so anyway last week
state department going back to russia um
the spokesperson uh ned price and i say
spokesperson because i don't know uh
ned's preferred pronouns
i think it would be [ __ ] and e
big capital e it's a shim yes yes
uh he gave this answer when uh ap
reporter matt lee asked him about uh a
russian false flag campaign and he said
yeah we really have this is a really
imminent threat and uh they said okay
and and what proof do you have he said
well i just i just said it and that's
the kind of accountability they expect
from the press watch what evidence do
you have to support the idea that there
is some propaganda film in the in in the
making
matt this is derived uh from information
known to the us government intelligence
information that we have declassified i
think you yeah okay well where where is
it where is there where is this
information
it is intelligence information that we
have declassified well where is it where
is the classified information i just
delivered it
no you made a series of allegations
would you would you like us to print out
the topper because you will see a
transcript of it
that you can print out for yourself it's
not evidence ned that's you saying it
that's not evidence i'm sorry
all right
what would you like matt
you just see that moment on his face
where he just wants out he's like oh
i'm not gonna get through this and
that's for those remember the boom goes
a dynamite clip kid where you can see
the moment that the kid mentally checks
out
please get me off it's like punchline
tom hanks someone help me exactly his
entire thing he goes on and on and on on
this telling that guy because i said it
that is the proof that you need that
it's real right like well hold on you
just said you declassified something
show me the receipts right and he would
never do it no this is pointing back so
who's spreading this information and at
the very least let's say we don't know
that it's disinformation okay that's
fine where the this is the white house
this is your government yeah and they
are deliberately obfuscating providing
information by the way all references
from today's show and every show
available at loudoutcrider.com the link
is in the description not saying we get
everything right but we try to make sure
that you are able to do your own
research and that you can call us on it
he's his take my word for it yeah no
even levar burton had a couple
six-year-olds to substantiate it
i'm just surprised that we actually had
a reporter pushing back
saying no no no sorry we can't just take
your word for it you can't just say it
where's the evidence yeah just show us
the evidence if it's obvious right
because you guys said everything about
russia when donald trump was president
we just took it as being then we know
that it was false and then all of these
intelligence agencies say this as well
and so we took it as gospel and you can
go back if you want if you want to use
george w bush weapons of mass
destruction is what everybody wanted a
plaster i know that there were other
things going on but we took it as gospel
right we have a reason to question
government it's a good thing well no the
government is the ex are the experts and
this is the problem when people say
trust the science what do you mean
coming from the cdc oh you only trust
government scientists now i'm not saying
that every single government scientist
is corrupt but what i'm saying is when
you declare the only experts and this is
what is happening when things are being
mislabeled
and and the white house is calling for
joe rogan to have his podcast be
mislabeled when he has doctors on what
they are saying is anything that goes
against the government established
science which by the way goes against
itself from six months ago uh needs to
be mislabeled what
the barometer here that's being used for
youtube facebook including instagram
twitter big tech
is the government that's the fact check
mechanism and these are the people in
charge of it by the way best thing you
can do we talk about comments smash the
like button if you're on youtube right
now if you want to make sure that this
gets through that algorithm and people
find it which they still probably won't
i still just ask that you smash that
like button smash it hard like brian
seltzer in the green room with the
makeup artist oh no i didn't specify the
gender no he didn't joe rogan beautiful
wife this is a conversation here that we
need to wife he doesn't like looking at
yes
and every day it's a slow drive
he has mirrors on the ceiling just so
that he can look at himself because he's
you know that's all he sees parks down
the street for three hours
eating wendy's buddy it was a long night
so sorry guys oh yeah i had to stay late
at the office
there's just nothing more than i love
than coming home to you hopefully being
on a business trip
oh you're here oh i had to sleep on the
couch again and the pillows that i put
in the shape of a guy she's cooking
naked
i know what i'm going to do for i'm
going to do for brian when he comes so
i'm going to cook and nothing but an egg
which by the way ladies always a crowd
pleaser for your husband just so you
know not brian's totally ships like
that's not so you could have like a
grief burn you should you should could
you put on like like a polar fleece yeah
that is not sanitary i could get germs
and my big delicious food
he's buying her valentine's lingerie
he's like look it's a parka from rei
would you like your favorite meal
dessert
it's a full burka
i will have the baked alaska with the
side of a baked alaska
the second one i'll put in my purse to
go
so
all right let's talk about completely
straight
guys i'm super straight stop it you guys
very straight i'm reliably straight
it's a heterosexual man bag yes yes of
course sometimes you need a place to put
your keys and
stuff you know and your rolodex of
strange male prostitutes exactly in your
black book of men you don't have sex
with that you have sex with
this list of guys that i would never
have sex with
ever because i love my wife more than
any
i love my wife more than any
thing
these are not keys to a series of condos
now
what do you have why do you have this
list of cardinals stop it
[Laughter]
so um
i'm confessing stelter now
let's talk about joe rogan this is
something that obviously happened this
weekend but i think some people have
missed the mark
um i'm not going to lie i'm i was upset
yes i was angry with no with joe as well
uh
and i'll explain to you why i'm more
angry of course with the people who've
tried to yeah i hate to use the term
cancel culture but the people who have
tried to destroy his life and his
livelihood now joe rogan is bigger than
them so good for him it shouldn't affect
him i hope he understands the power that
he has unfortunately he's caved a little
bit and i just
it that makes it harder for everybody
else and i have a lot of respect for joe
i think he's a good guy i've spent some
time with him i just so it's always hard
for me just full disclosure to be
objective when i know somebody
um so joe rogan has uh you know gotten
in trouble last week it was about covert
misinformation and do you know how you
know that it wasn't about coveted
misinformation
because when that didn't work now they
decided they're going to oh you know
what actually look he's also racist
someone put together a montage out of
context of joe rogan having said the n
word in case you guys have missed it uh
and you must be living under a rock at
this point or you know or just hiding
out from your home like stelter what's
going on he just if he emerges there's
gonna be six more weeks of
winter of street fairs um
six more weeks of gay pride yes
hot dog eating contest
oh my gosh he just has that tape of
kobayashi on a loop like a morphine drip
he loves it i'm just training
[Laughter]
so uh here is joe rogan the hit piece
that they put together which really if
you look at every clip individually is
not a hit piece of him saying the n word
over the last 12 plus years [ __ ] i
already said [ __ ] d is just like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] she's calling you a [ __ ] it's
like this boy that he's a [ __ ] and
starts calling them [ __ ] bird [ __ ]
there should be a word like [ __ ]
especially word [ __ ] that's our [ __ ]
about [ __ ] he says [ __ ] die a
[ __ ] and then our [ __ ] start saying
[ __ ] questions
no no they added to it but you can watch
all those right away when i watch like
oh that's him quoting a chris rock
routine oh that's him telling a story
about a racist who called someone an n
word oh i know that where he's talking
about hey how this word is different in
the english language here's the thing oh
i thought he was ordering coffee yes
oh you mean this was out of context
that's crazy yeah
oh no i thought he was saying goodnight
to his kids right oh so strange
it's all it's almost like uh they did it
on purpose to make them look bad it's
almost like that yeah and they want you
to think here's what it is though too
it's not that uh they think he's a rate
here look they don't think that joe
rogan is a racist because you know who
wouldn't be upset by this an actual
racist you're not going to use this
against the robert byrd type because
they just go like yeah i said it because
they're still saying it they don't care
they use this against people who they
know are not racist so that they have to
defend themselves as not racist they
wouldn't use it against an actual racist
this is not a mode of attack that would
be used
against someone like whoever david duke
or robert byrd someone who is actually
in the clan they wouldn't use it when
you see this line of attack you know
that it is exclusively used against
someone who they know is not racist
because that person will be forced into
defending themselves as not being a
racist now joe rogan issued an apology
with which i strongly disagree yeah and
i'll explain to you why i think it was
very thoughtful though and i think the
way that he delivered the apology was as
well delivered as an as an ill-advised
apology like this could be delivered but
for people who missed it he posted this
on his instagram and we'll have of
course links to all the full clips uh
loudest crowder.com with the sources the
references here's to rogan's apology
hello friends
um
i'm making this video to talk about is
that a turtleneck or no neck regretful
and shameful thing that i've ever had to
talk about publicly
there's a video that's out that's a
compilation of me saying the n-word
it's a video that's made of clips taken
out of context of me of 12 years of
conversations on my podcast and it's all
smushed together and it looks horrible
even to me now i know that to most
people there is no context where a white
person is ever allowed to say that
that's right most people don't find it
publicly on a podcast and i agree with
that now
i haven't said it in years but for a
long time
when i would bring that word up like if
it would come up in conversation and
stay instead of saying the n word i
would just say the word i thought as
long as it was in context people would
understand what i was doing like that
context was
part of the clip we were talking about
red fox how red fox said that word on
television in the 1970s and how times
have changed so much since then or about
how richard pryor used it as one of the
titles of one of his albums actually i
do hope that this can be a teachable
moment part one and two for anybody that
doesn't realize
how offensive
that word can be coming out of a white
person's mouth
in context or out of
my sincere and
humble apologies i wish there was more
that i could say but
all of this is just me talking from the
bottom of my heart it makes me sick
watching that video and there was also
something about a planet of the apes
joke that he made where he you know yeah
which i mean in fairness he was on
ambien and they're gonna overdose him
and then next season his show is just
gonna be called the rogans with john
goodman yes
surprise cameo from whoopi it's not
about race mm-hmm well i i think
genuinely
i understand what he's saying i
genuinely do but i just feel that this
shows that it's being
you know this is being forced i feel i i
don't know i just feel like it's being
forced to make you
feel this way right yeah they they want
you to believe that this is how you feel
yeah and i i don't know i don't agree
with say what you and then i have
something i want to no that's it i want
to say yeah i don't understand why
saying it coming out of a white person's
mouth
well it doesn't matter whose mouth it
comes out of i just let me say it
doesn't thank you dude i disagree with i
would say the inverse is true that the
only time it should be considered
completely impermissible is if you are
using it in a racist context accusing
some calling someone the n-word if you
are quoting somebody if you're quoting a
richard pryor album i don't think he
actually the name of the album he said
that he named these albums to screw with
white people he wanted to make them
uncomfortable who am i to rename his art
who am i to sing along with tupac or
sing along in my car with kanye and say
and uh n-word this is some it's almost
offensive to the artist because this is
something that's meant to be consumed by
many people there's a huge difference
between the context of quoting somebody
or the context of actually being
supportive of a black person's art and
the context of using it
to deliberately insult somebody and by
the way my entire life i have never once
heard a white person say it in its
racist context outside of one time out
of bob evans in virginia and i told you
i was incredibly surprised because it
was that abnormal let me just say this
about joe rogan here
his planet of the apes joke that he made
okay now i've been on joe rogan's show a
bunch of times and i've been talking
about this for a long time keep in mind
i've had i've been dropped by managers
back in 2009 agents i had problems with
meetings at people at viacom i remember
saying look
this is what's happening they're going
to come for you and so many people who
are on this show and even i think the
first time i appeared on joe rogan
saying no not you know not with comedy
comedy's a last bastion you know it's
it's different so
they didn't believe it joe rogan was
imprudent back then to make his planet
of the apes comment joke not because the
joke is impermissible not because the
joke is that offensive not because
anything he said was offensive but he
was imprudent because he thought they
wouldn't come for him
he said that yeah he said that before
they always will come for you and now
i believe he is wrong to apologize
because that's done under the guise that
they have
any
intention of forgiving him of course
they don't it was covid now it's this
you apologize for this they're just
going to move on to something else and
this makes it more difficult for other
people because it sets a precedent where
people think they have to apologize for
things that do not require an apology i
think he was wrong back then to think
that they wouldn't come for him and i
think that he's incorrect right now to
apologize look even if you think you're
wrong and i want to be clear about this
this is a difference
this is a difference between uh there's
a difference between a consensual
relationship in an abusive relationship
a loving relationship an abusive
relationship in a loving relationship
where both parties
are actually trying to make a
relationship work because they care
about each other when you think you're
wrong you apologize it's a very good
rule to follow if you're married if
you're in a long-term relationship be
quick to apologize be quick to forgive
you do that
the relationship works no matter what
happens quick to apologize quick to
forgive quick to say you're sorry
recognize your faults quick to give
grace
an abusive relationship
is where someone is trying to gaslight
you someone is trying to manipulate you
into apologizing and then they will use
that to hammer in your faults because
they have no interest in accepting your
apology in the first place that's what's
happening now this is not a loving
relationship this is not the left
wanting joe rogan to recognize some
faults and improve upon it so they can
have a working relationship going
forward this is a relationship where
they want to destroy him where they want
to take everything that he has so here's
the deal even if you think you're wrong
people out there even if you think
you're wrong even if you do regret it
if you are in a loving relationship sure
you apologize you don't apologize in
front of the enemy even when you think
you're wrong i down the line but if
winston churchill thought that he made
some strategic errors in world war ii
you don't say man i made a mistake while
hitler's still on the march afterward
you say maybe this would have been a
better idea so i actually don't even
agree if you think you're wrong a lot of
people say if i think i'm wrong i need
to apologize not right now
you don't do it right now
because they're not going to forgive you
they're just going to use it to attack
you you do not bend the knee to the mob
ever even if you think you are wrong you
do it later on that's just the abc those
are the abcs of me that's what i think
you guys can comment below and let me
know what you think if you're in a
relationship with someone you care about
you apologize if it's someone who's
seeking to hurt you you don't apologize
you don't show weakness at that point in
time and here's the thing it's not just
some people on twitter
this is the and we've been through this
we're going to go back to the vox
apocalypse and talk about it because
i've lived this exactly
exactly when people tried to get us
removed from youtube here and then i was
mentioned by sitting senators
and cnn the exact same thing a hit list
a real and we survived it
so let's look at this sort of gaggle of
bullies jim acosta and brian salters uh
hear them talking about how joe rogan
should be kicked off spotify what is joe
rogan now saying
he is now apologizing and we're going to
find out if that's enough for spotify
the company that has an exclusive
distribution deal with him jim this is
all coming to light because of the
recent controversy about anti-vaccine
rhetoric on rogan's podcast how are the
two relationships they decided to quit
the service one of them in the uh
pointed out this video
and pointed out that the language rogan
has used around race in the past is just
as or maybe even more problematic than
his rhetoric about vaccines typically in
the past when a video like the one at
the beginning of this uh segment uh that
we aired of joe rogan saying the n word
repeatedly over and over and over again
over the course of many of his episodes
i mean that would be enough for somebody
to lose their job there are many
examples including in hollywood and
entertainment where people have uh have
lost their roles for less than this and
that may be why spotify is being so
quiet at the same time i want to
recognize the reasons why rogan has lots
of fans millions of fans people want to
hear his candid conversations but
there's a difference between that
between candid in-depth conversations
and the kind of vile that's in this
compilation yeah okay a couple of things
first off there are a few flaws there do
you notice he said people were
unsubscribing really do you have those
numbers they're not available
where's the misinformation label people
aren't subscribing because of what joe
rogan said are you sure about that
and by the way does it counterbalance
all of the new paying subscribers
because joe rogan was signed to spotify
that's misinformation right there and
he's saying other people have been
canceled for saying far less well here's
the thing joe rogan's not an employee
dummy
joe rogan's not an employee of spotify
they have some kind of whatever it is a
distribution deal a licensing deal he's
not like you he's not a patsy for the
higher ups hoping for jeff zucker's job
people need to understand this
difference and certainly of all my most
of all my god joe rogan
i hope that joe rogan understands he he
can't be fired by these people look this
is the same thing i'll get into what
happened with us
no one employee i don't have an employer
i am the employer some people sign the
backs of checks some people sign the
fronts of checks and the only reason i'm
able to do it is because of you the
viewer not like pbs where we say viewers
like you but then we get tens of
millions of dollars in federal funding
just you we're not funded by a foreign
caliphate we're not funded by someone at
cnn who tells us what to say it's mug
club you guys can join up lottery with
crowder.com club we appreciate the
support you'll always have free content
here on youtube as long as it's a loud
rumble but we do an extra hour of show
that we know we could never do on
youtube every single day this is the
only way that we make revenue and some
sponsorships with sponsors who have the
balls to to not run off right but yeah
but yeah i'm with you no i just think
you're absolutely right about all of it
i think
that when it comes down to apologizing
to a mob it doesn't matter if he's
apologizing to black people specifically
who were offended for using the n-word
that's one thing but i don't believe
that he ever used it maliciously so
the reason why he thought he was
untouchable which i don't believe that
he thought he was untouchable to be
honest i think it was because at one
point comedy was supposed to be all in
context right comedy cannot exist unless
it's within context right and if
anything is looked at as a joke it is a
joke and it's that simple that's why you
would you would love it if everything
that we did was looked at like it was
supposed to be well and i don't think he
uh to clarify people think that's what i
was saying i was never suggesting that
he thought he was untouchable but
exactly what you said here's the deal i
lived in a very different world right
we're back when i was 19 i was banned
from a college because this is a when i
was 19 years old would it would have
been 2000
seven i was banned from a lady's foot
locker but that's go on well see that's
okay because now i'm allowed in every
lady's foot locker because i just set
the penn state records but he um
he thought and i was always telling
people look you just you're saying that
that comedy is is untouchable in context
because you haven't gone through what
i've gone through you don't know right
now what i am saying is permissible but
it's going to get worse i've had this
conversation with many comedians and
comedians would be on the show and say
no i don't think that's what's going to
happen comedy i'm saying i've lived it
i've had agents drop me i've had
managers drop me i've been banned from
school i've been banned from comedy
clubs i've had bookers complain at this
point it's a clean act but i would say
things that would be considered
politically incorrect and i experienced
it and i was trying to sound the alarm
saying before the term existed the
social justice warriors are coming so
and they're going no it's not going to
happen in comedy yes it will and if it
hasn't happened for you yet it's either
because that overton window hasn't been
moved far enough yet or you are not big
enough yet that's the only reason they
are coming for
all of you and it's not because they
actually think that you're racist what
they want to do with joe rogan is this
what they want to do is joe rogan has to
go interview francis ingano or curtis
blades or someone like that after a ufc
fight and he's afraid does this guy
think i'm a racist because he saw
something out of context what they want
to do is again it's like an abusive
relationship alienate you and isolate
you from all of the people who were your
friends who now may have this
misconception of you that's a big
component of this too yeah they wanted
to do it with me and make it seem like i
was homophobic this is what they wanted
to do and you know that being said i
mean you know it's like a spider like i
don't have to touch
you're not afraid of gay people at all
who's that's the stupidest terp does
anyone know anybody who is afraid of
homosexuals it's the stupidest term
again it's a made-up term just to
silence you fearfully into submission
now let's remember this in context
i don't know if you know who else has
said this and i don't think i think he's
a racist for different reasons but
former vice president joe biden hard r
we already have a [ __ ] mayor we don't
need any more [ __ ] big shots oh what
weird
and by the way he's still saying it is
he on spotify still he's still saying
here
niggered here nick
well
not to me not to mention he uses the f
word you know he what he says about the
nazis nazi frags now look
in fairness though his brain is firing
yes
[Laughter]
yeah just every human being on this
planet everybody has said vile things
everybody has said awful things we are
all human beings right everybody makes
mistakes everybody does things right and
wrong and when i even see that video i
go yeah a lot of that's just people
talking right yeah sorry that's just the
reality if you're sitting there throwing
stones at somebody
there's no
part of this that is genuine no the only
part of this is to take control well
here's a good example of that is you
know we were talking about context and
of course the left says there is no
context in which it's permissible so now
people have been circulating the former
vice president joe biden video but if
you look it's been defended by people on
the left right here's a headline from
media joe rogan defenders have been
circulating videos of joe biden saying
the n word here's the full story and it
goes on to explain
the context of it and why it's
permissible so oh so context applies to
the sitting former vice president but
context doesn't apply to a comedian on a
podcast who by the way was saying it in
a far less pernicious way this is the
point it's not about whether it's wrong
it's not even about the context you
don't apologize
they're not demanding an apology of
former vice president joe biden right
because in all contexts but you're
demanding one of joe rogan not only that
you're demanding that he lose his
livelihood because you don't care about
the context don't apologize to those
people animals well and when we had the
kyle writtenhouse trial total opposites
yeah
we had the trial on for kyle rittenhouse
the uh the guy that ran around saying
shoot me and word shoot me and we're
right we we actually said we want you to
see this you mean the blm advocate yeah
can we pause once again i want to hold
your thoughts this right now pete
buttking is on cnn look at this it says
delta ceo asks justice department to put
unruly passengers on no fly list do you
see the problem now that's not a free
market how many bailouts has delta
received by the way you want to look at
the companies that receive the most
amount of bailouts you have banks you
have car companies you have airline
companies this these are the industries
of course that americans know and love
now they're saying they're they're
asking the justice department to put
unruly passengers on no fly list well
what if you have a medical initiation in
you don't put a mask on yeah we've had
video circulate where those people have
been asked to exit a plane i'm not
talking about people punching each other
let's do it right obviously spirit
airlines is not making this request
because that's their clientele or the
golden corral neither one send your
unruly mother send them on over to
spirit if you want the big front seats
you better put up your dukes right well
they just merged with frontiers so
there's like a wild west stuff out in
this [ __ ] that's like a 5.4 billion by
the way 5.4 billion and now they're
saying hey look you build us up justice
department can you get rid of these
unruly passengers we know what dealt we
know that delta is a vote company you've
seen what they've been doing in the past
and now how do they define unruly it's
already illegal to start a fight it's
already illegal to make a bomb threat
it's already illegal to actually cause a
disruption on a commercial airplane you
know that right that's the law it's just
like hate speech it's already illegal to
violently threaten someone it's already
illegal to call people to violence but
then we establish no no we mean speech
that people don't like so i want to see
what they're asking here and what pete
buttgig is oh look he must be using his
rogaine to be looked at at a moment like
this uh and at the same time we also
have to recognize that there's clearly
something uh deeper that's going on in
our society that makes anybody think
that it's acceptable or tolerable to
behave this way you simply should not
behave this way on an airplane you
shouldn't behave this way on the ground
either
but in uh in air travel it's a unique
risk and it's especially important that
we're backing up flight attendants and
flight crews that are essential workers
they have real heroes yeah our travel
and transportation sector through this
pandemic they deserve respect
and deserves
and of course they deserve better you
mean the rudest people on the planet two
and a half years of uh this
is the country's roads and bridges and
delayed flights
this is we've never seen this in our
lifetime we've never seen this in our
lifetime the amount of control from only
a handful of big companies and they are
so blatantly comfortable with letting
you know that they are working hand in
hand with the government to eliminate
from society people who have a specific
point of view you know the half who
elects presidents you were saying
something about jordan i was saying yeah
so when rosenbaum was running around
earlier in the day and they had video of
him shouting shoot me inward right we
had that we played that and they were
believing it and we're like no no no we
need you to see what he actually said
because his the context of what was
going on really matters you don't need
to have this bleep to cover it joe rogan
in most of those was quoting other
people and what they were saying
i understand that you don't like a word
i get it that it's voldemort nobody can
say it other than black people or when
you're singing a song or in in the
private of your own home apparently
because they said you can't say it and
have another black person see it right
you can't say it in public or my god on
a podcast
it is totally unbelievable that there is
a word that is okay for some people to
say and other people to say in quoting
them and go wait a minute you're white
you can't say that right how is that not
racism i don't mean anything by the word
by the way i'm only saying what tupac
said they want you to believe that the
person who quotes
in in praise of a black artist someone
who quotes that is just as racist as the
person who's uh beating the slave in
roots exactly they want you to believe
it's the same it doesn't make any sense
you're talking about red fox and richard
pryor who broke the mold in the 70s as
black comedians following you know like
cosby and and dick gregory who was i
mean i would probably say the pioneer of
that guy at least cosby never used the
n-word no it's very very very true
you know that's still on spotify by the
way he was an ob gyn that worked out of
his basement on the cosmos who knew wow
that is weird work from home but when
you look at that though you're like
of all the professions to pick why did
his recliner have stirrups all he did
was leave just little see little like
little seedlings
little breadcrumbs no breadcrumbs all
the way little roofies
yeah they were just a little trail of
roofies all the way up down to my place
and my dad and pick him up his candy and
they got a gingerbread house i'm just a
monster
don't pull your pants down and don't use
the n-word blah i'm gonna rape you
you know it's not just uh bill cosby
who's still on spotify r kelly still on
spotify marilyn manson is still on
spotify exactly what what the hell's
about it with you the people who are
pulling off of spotify or just anybody
who wants attention it's like oh joe
chumbo wumbo wants to take a stand yeah
talking to darren he's like yeah
herman's hermits is finally coming out
like look yeah
lara trump pulled she's like i'm pulling
my podcast from spotify and they're just
they're stuck went up 9 000 maroon 5
said
get him off or we're going to add our
music to spotify yeah there's no way and
he will
be banned
oh no
oh god was it half away hard away
yeah no penny hardaway has a podcast and
he's also removing that
pennywise
[Laughter]
oh marcy playground's gone i'm sorry joe
we just gotta cut ties yeah we're done
it's just what will we do without
messing behind yes
we try to walk away but we can't he
tried to say the word and his stump
no it's clear spotify we're still here
i'm tired of hearing everyone say
it's
so stupid it's just it's a comic i
here's the thing i knew this was going
to happen uh yeah i was sounding the
alarm yeah and let me tell you how i
know it and let me i only know one way
to handle things just so people
understand maybe there's a more tactful
way to do it
it's just not the way i do things it's a
mack truck you pull out the emergency
brake that's about the only way i know
how to be successful at anything in life
i'd like to learn a greater skill set
where i can have some more finesse but
i'm not there yet vox
of course partnered with nbc universal
one of the biggest companies in the
world tried to do this with yours truly
for people who have missed it this is
sorry the vox adpocalypse happened uh it
was a big deal i'm sorry to all the
creators who were harmed they created a
new set of rules the crowder rule
because it wasn't a violation of any
guidelines and there's advertiser
friendly guidelines now there's the
borderline content in the industry
people refer to that as
behind closed doors the crowd are rule
sorry
it's all your fault and this is exactly
what they did to me back in 2019
i appreciate that they put the reel
together because you know now i don't
need to address it anymore
before we get to the video uh with our
favorite favorite elizabeth right
it's ridiculous it's bonkers you're
being given a free pass as a crappy
writer because you're gay that's center
line and his little queer graph there
well now the graph is queer
violence filth okay so the little queer
could eat his chips all nonchalantly
it's code for rape mr queer eating chips
on the vox channel chip chip chip that
you can eat just one dick this is what
mr gay vox wants to do mr let's be queer
from
what were you holding gay latino from
bots even his hand movement in fast
motion is gay now we're here with the
short-haired angry lesbian on skype and
cable news taking these bitching two gay
guys sitting there eating banana we get
the symbolism there
is hiding in a closet two weeks later
probably along to his next pride parade
out but this guy on the gay semi latino
votes oh okay so you really are just
angry a little queer all right i can't
deal with this sprite anymore okay he
just sashays across without it like just
stop that gang [ __ ] sprite is wrong
now he could be a draenei your honor but
how many lispy angry sprites and vox
sachet across your screen and try and
tell you otherwise or you by the way the
gay mexican guy the gay latino v-neck
gay mexican the mexican gay guy used to
work mexican gay latino there at uh
uh gay latino from vodka token vox gay
atheist sprite with surprisingly
surprisingly flaccid chess considering
how finnish it is very bizarre to me
that feels less than gay people and more
at one guy right do you remember and by
the way we did plenty of critiques of
other people too but it was also because
you know his the guy's handle was uh gay
wonk
use those terms and of course the
grossly offensive 1940s term sprite yeah
[Music]
by the way youtube co-produced a show
with vox we later found out i found that
i was at the movie theater i was at the
movie theater and they were announcing
some new show on youtube and it was vox
something and it was youtube producing
what oh
of course so here's the thing after that
same thing as with joe rogan the media
sitting senators politicians were uh
forced to address and some call for uh
some were calling for
me to lose my ability and because they
can't fire me but lose my ability to
broadcast freely to you we heard the
allegations from mr carlos mazza
who uploaded a video
on twitter with a compilation works at
vox.com who works at vox.com yes
um they speak in front of a vox
sponsored
[Laughter]
different video pieces
right in the middle of crowder's channel
um putting them together right and and
um asked us to take action like again i
want to say there were many videos and i
looked at the you know certainly at the
compilation video so when the team said
we believe this is non-violent this
doesn't violate our rules you agreed
with that well let me explain to you yes
you interrupt me again i will speak to
the manager you agree
um
i i agree that that was the right
decision youtube dragged its feet before
taking any action against conservative
commentator stephen crowder despite
being informed of crowder's two-year
homophobic harassment campaign against
journalists carla harassment we also got
carlos mazza he's the host of the series
strikethrough on vox.com he says he's
been harassed for years by this
controversial youtuber named steven
crowder he recently tweeted a whole
montage of offensive so-called jokes
youtube was about to start pride month
and rock the rainbow colors and claim to
care about lgbt people and they were
helping this guy build an audience base
of 4 million subscribers whose only real
content was making fun of me for being
queer why are you gay yeah that was our
only content content yeah yeah exactly
and by the way youtube was helping us
they they just could not stop helping us
build that platform why do they always
have the one person who i know sits
right behind the camera that when they
talk and go lgbtq they go
yeah
that's just what they just think that
now they're
the hodge twins came in don don lemon
had on a show like man we were in an
airport man and then we walk into the
hotel cnn's on the screen and we just
see stephen and his dad go on
[Laughter]
it was carlos mazza that was disgusting
i think well he got fired from vox and
all this stuff and look it was never
about that guy don't wish him any ill
will the issue was why do you get fired
from vox yeah i have no idea producing
terrible the point is vox it didn't work
youtube google uh took a nosedive
actually when they did that the vox
apocalypse happened yeah and uh
i mean you know you guys want to go some
people have already put together the hit
reel you know good luck here's what i
think now
um
we survived we grew through it and of
course at that point we had a record
number of you guys signing up mug club
subscribers and that usually is what
happens because you understand that not
only it's the only way that we can
continue to survive and we have a lot of
you now surprising amount of you
watching at mug club uh i think probably
not because you also you know you get
like an hour of extra show but you know
that it could go away at any moment so
we did apologize but this is how i think
joe rogan and everyone moving forward
just
it worked for us the blueprint this is
how we apologized i would also like to
apologize to drake the rapper for
referring to him as a quote buttersoft
[ __ ]
and claiming that his only redeeming
quality as a performer was when he was
shot into permanent paralysis on
degrassi
i'd also like to apologize to justice
ruth bader ginsburg for implying that
she's long been deceased
and even though i don't have verifiable
proof to the contrary i do realize my
observations were conducted in poor
taste and ill-timed i'd also like to
retract my comment about representative
dan crenshaw implying that his mug shot
would quote resemble that of an angry
pirate shift manager in a brooks
brothers catalog store
and that would be quote the stuff of
children's nightmares
to my dear friend and esteemed colleague
ben shapiro i sincerely apologize for
implying that you're a greedy shekel
hoarder i'd like to issue an apology to
tess holliday for incorrectly implying
that her blood type was biologically
comparable to that of pudding
she is both brave and beautiful and i
should have done more to celebrate that
also an apology to the general pudding
corporation for associating their
product with test holiday
that's the only way i know how to do it
so sorry smash that like button right
now if you're watching on youtube and i
think what just happened is uh back then
i had a 10. it's not like i aged 20
years and five no it didn't happen not
at all
by the way i know that we're not
supposed to mention these guys but
there's another compilation floating
around out there of other people i'm not
saying their name if you watch this show
we've we've buried them in the past
just look at that is it my only fans
youtube you've got yeah youtube you've
got another problem right if rogan's a
problem for spotify then that's got to
be a problem for youtube right which by
the way you might want to change the url
from
onlyfans.com dave says the n word to
just
throw them off the scent but i thought
people find it spicy when i do well they
do find it spicy but uh i don't know if
the juice is worth the squeeze
also cancelled south carolina just me
pulling up and yelling it at bus stop
and getting your ass kicked
to me being beaten then pulling up on
the tarmac to spirit hey hey guys
and then the next shot's just you in an
ambulance
dave here again i'm on the south side no
matter what city it is yeah i'm about to
get the [ __ ] kicked out of me in front
of cricket wireless i'm at the corner of
malcolm x and martin luther king
boulevard ah this ought to be fun let's
roll these dice
going to the golden corral to take the
last steak yeah
heading on in
[Laughter]
what spirit seat is mine we're gonna
find out in a minute i'm about to send
back this popeye's chicken sandwich see
how it goes
i'm about to just about to purchase the
last one and let everyone know
it's all just jokes
and what i think you know look if you i
i like joe rogan uh
go ahead and
just keep supporting who you support the
fact that this is like sounds like we're
going into war
is so weird like life is not that bad
it's just a podcast right it's listen to
who you want to listen to enjoy it and
i'm really glad that you support us you
support steven who has the balls to keep
doing his show even when i i'm just
shocked that i even watch these clips
and these people are talking about you
well this is so weird man this is what
they want to do and you know just like
joe rogan um obviously we're not as big
as joe rogan but certainly bigger than
any any show on cnn and any late night
show as far as you know you uh viewers
in the demo
and they want to eliminate it yeah and
that's that's really what it comes down
to they want to eliminate competition
and they have the assistance and the the
full support of the united states
government and that is what's scary yeah
the united states government is becoming
a mafia strong man basically you just
call these guys when you have a problem
and they come in and fix it with the
power that they have but everything that
dave just said watch whatever you want
to watch listen to whatever you want to
listen to that's what they want to take
away that's what they want to take away
that's why if you type in steven crowder
change my mind abortion maybe they fixed
it you'll find something from pbs they
make it so you can't even find what you
want to find and that's why we always
tell you monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern you guys have to tune in
bookmark it best thing you can do is
subscribe over at rumble mug club
because even if you subscribe even if
you hit the notification bell
you may not find
this show that's that's the issue people
are not allowed to choose what that was
what we thought would be the beauty of
the internet right well there's no more
gatekeeper the gatekeepers are the same
as always and now they're more powerful
than ever because they learned oh wait a
second it's no longer the fcc we can
just have the government declare
something misinformation it doesn't have
to actually be set guidelines or
regulations that we understand like you
did on radio or television and worse
than the fcc is the mob now who works
hand in hand with big tech and often
people in government to try and
eliminate your career even though
there's no actual violation well yeah
and don't be like the rock
yeah it was like oh i totally side with
rogue and then all of a sudden i was
like no no i don't that man stood by the
movie jungle cruise yes
i'd rather be sodomized with a coke
bottle while being called a chalk demon
for an hour and a half then watch them
well dave how did you know what stelter
did tuesday you have to pay for that
typically i i see well it's
it's called tipsy tuesday yes
you taste me well i'd like to share the
world a coke
and a smile for me
perfect harmony
one in the front oh lord one in the ring
no there's one thing for sure i'm not
queer
reliable source says
that's me now
[Laughter]
uh yesterday
going on with this now we have gofundme
so here's the thing are you free on
spotify well not really are you free on
youtube well not really are you free on
facebook twitter
now uh what about gofundme which was
supposed to be again all of you go fund
me it's supposed to be fun me youtube
fund me youtube it's supposed to be
about you not cnn abc nbc cbs not viacom
nbc universe none of that gofundme was
supposed to be anyone could go out there
and start raising money what happened
the screws got tight let's tighten the
vice a little bit here there was the
freedom convoy of course in canada the
uh biggest
uh uprising that i've ever seen is for a
peaceful protest in canadian government
finally um and they raised uh uh 10
million dollars actually but you know
before we go to that let's show you
how the arms of government are treating
entire the police acknowledged not one
act of violence let's see how the ottawa
police
government
is treating these protesters that they
came in and they were taking the fuel
they were having force there and not
letting anybody in they were taking fuel
with their
weapons
looks cold
yeah not letting anybody in
they're taking the fuel out of the
trucks
not out but they can't resupply them
yeah they're seizing them
okay the police also by the way unless
you take that think that's been taken
out of context the police announced
anyone trying to supply protesters with
any materials would be subject to arrest
now i could understand that for example
like if it was black lives matter and
you know pallets of bricks sure yeah of
course that would be leaving them there
or you know like pipe bombs that kind of
thing or you know anything that might be
used to burn down a walgreens
when there's never been one single act
of violence it's just truckers honking
their horn
they did vandalize the terry fox
memorial by uh draping it with a flag
they'll never untie that and then they
took it off never
um so this is the kind of horror that
has been seen at these protests in
canada and again
really what it comes down to is you
either believe in the idea of peaceful
protests
or not and in canada you don't really
have first amendment protections but
contrast with black lives matter seattle
chaz chop all of these
movements for crying out loud the
women's march had more acts of violence
and vandalism and people don't say we
need to stop supplying them so gofundme
was trying to steal let me be clear
steal there was 10 million dollars
raised for uh these truckers at gofundme
and gofundme was trying to steal it now
there's a little bit of a happy ending
here but not entirely um
gofundme took down the freedom convoy
2022 page on friday claiming the protest
was now an occupation that's important
the word occupation because they don't
care gofundme originally stated that
donors had two weeks to ask for a refund
before it was redistributed to quote
credible and established charities and
we'll get to what those have been there
from gofundme in the past by the way
one's an actual occupation
[Laughter]
so um this redistributing redistribution
plan got a lot of people upset of course
desantis being the bulldog that he is um
the florida governor said that they were
going to be investigating for fraud
there are a lot of a.g said all right oh
yeah this is something we're going to do
so then gofundme immediately reversed
their course and said everyone will be
automatically refunded now what would
have been best is if gofundme said all
right
of course we're going to allow the
gofundme the what's supposed to be an
independent platform for you know
raising money we're going to allow it to
go to the people who haven't committed
an act of violence and they're
peacefully protesting their government
instead by the way you think the
canadian got do you think the canadian
government didn't know about this you
don't think there were some calls that
were made it's not a conspiracy when you
have jen saki saying we think spotify
should do more you don't think that
trudeau made a call from his bunker to
go fund me i can't substantiate that i
just believe it to be so so um
has he come out of hiding yet no has
anybody actually seen trudeau well
there's gonna be six more weeks of
blackface oh no he's been hiding 10
million dollars of shoe polish yes been
hiding a banana the kiwi stock just went
up but their supply chain went down
totally acceptable again and that's in
context yes let's let's look at some
other conservative right-leaning people
causes that gofundme again you don't
live in a free society if the rules are
not applied equally right
it's not that we have rules not that we
have laws how would you feel if there
were laws and people actually complain
about you know more uh black americans
being caught for minor drug offenses
that's true there's a little more to
that story because usually these are
sort of uh these are offenses that are
congruent with either other offenses
simultaneously or there have been
multiple offenses before especially if
you look at clinton in stating the three
strike law but that being said i
understand why people are upset and if
you believe that black people are simply
being arrested for smoking some
marijuana even though they smoke it at
the same rate that white people do the
point is that would be injustice why
because we have a law but it's not being
applied equally now imagine
if it were more severe than that and the
law said white people can smoke
marijuana and black people can't not
that i was being enforced unequally but
that was the law that's what we're
seeing here with these big tech
platforms who are arms of the government
you are not free just because you have
laws
you are only a free country if the law
is applied equally so let's look at
gofundme they discontinued kyle
rittenhouse they discontinued uh an
anti-vaccine mandate lawsuit they
discontinued trump rally uh fundraisers
um and the company vowed in january 2021
that they would they would continue to
remove fundraisers that quote spread
misinformation about the election
promote conspiracy theories and
contribute to or participate in attacks
on u.s democracy now let's compare
attacks on u.s democracy well that makes
sense here are the other ones that they
actively supported black lives matter
riots jacob blake the man who by the way
his uh his i don't know wife his partner
was on you know called because he had
raped her and she called the cops when
he was there kidnapping his own children
he tried to
attack the cops with a knife jacob blake
that was allowed to stay on there were
bail there was bail money for pedophiles
not to mention jazz chop so we're
talking about an occupation oh wait wait
wait that sounds that's an actual
occupation yeah where they set up
roadblocks and handed out guns and
declared it an autonomous zone by the
way also lit stuff on fire there were
also multiple people murdered in chaz
shop this is not news to anyone
reference is available at crowder.com
you can go back and watch our entire
episode these were allowed to stay but
truckers
most of whom are vaccinated but are
protesting a government mandate entirely
peacefully even it's not even an
accusation that they haven't been
peaceful
getting removed
is the law are the rules applied equally
that's what this is about yeah and the
answer is absolutely not and this i
think this pissed me off more than
anything over the weekend because if
gofundme can take money from people and
like you said initially saying we're
going to redistribute it fine look if
you're going to be if you're going to be
a socialist and you're not going to
allow us to do anything if you're going
to be a communist whatever the
authoritarian fine we get it we
understand who you are we've got other
people we can go to to get funds to
causes that we support you don't just
get to give that to other people because
people gave you money right you
immediately give it back and that's
where people were they were like look
we'll do chargebacks on it which would
have been fantastic do you know how many
thousands and thousands of chargebacks
would have happened to them that would
have destroyed part of their business
that would have been great explain to
people who don't know what charges and
chargeback on that credit card it's like
they've taken my funds and they're not
using it for what like if somebody comes
and buys wine and i charge them for wine
they didn't actually buy you can charge
back and they would actually hit me i
would have to pay that back to the
credit card company so i would be left
holding the bank hey johnny boy sorry my
guy out there uh make sure that we uh
call up uh gerald's wine clientele list
i have something to talk to them about
exactly but this only happened because
of the pressure
yeah right well you know and these
charges you back you don't use your
credit what are you writing to check
geez
i want to hear from you the people who
comment because i know we have a lot of
libertarian people who do you think this
is still a question of the free market
i think it's silly at this point no not
at all go go make your own okay well you
know what i will i'll go build my own
platform i'll start it with gofundme
i'll go fund me removed you well you
know what i'll create an app well the
apple store removed you uh well i guess
i'll start a channel well they removed
you
oh i think i'll stay alive in my truck
well we can't give you gas even though
it's or
or anything else and by the way one
thing we didn't mention shopify one of
the largest online e-commerce platforms
in the universe
no stephen crowder you can't sell
merchandise through oh yeah that's true
i've been banned from shopping there's a
bad shirt no it wasn't a bad shirt they
said i didn't like what i said ah oh
okay yeah how about you can go to
crowdershop.com we have a different uh
stuff by the way people who are uh uh
talking about how some shirts have been
yeah we've had to change vendors thrice
thrice because people said oh we don't
we don't want to be uh we don't like
what you say yeah all right that's fine
but this is what happens this is how it
starts and then they feel emboldened of
course by the government if you're delta
you just saw it delta says
well we've got the full backing of the
united states government great you think
do you think there's going to be an
investigation into gofundme from the
federal government no of course not
they're doing their bidding do you think
that former vice president joe biden do
you think nancy pelosi do you think any
of these people want to push for
transparency laws with big tech no they
want to push for more regulation so that
they can have more control over these
companies when you talk about fascist
authoritarian governments people tried
to say that donald trump was a fascist
donald trump
never tried to shut anyone didn't try to
shut these places down he was saying
they need to lose their tax exempt
status because they need to be they need
to pick
are they a public platform are they a
publisher they need to stop censoring
right now you have a government telling
people to censor the gut so if you
believe that only the government can
censor what happens when the government
is telling other people to censor and of
course they have the purse string so
they can say if you censor i'll give you
a little bit of we'll give you a little
bit of a tax break here if you censor
we'll make sure we have a meeting we'll
have a summit and you'll be included if
you don't well you know what we don't
know what's going to happen to you it
would be a shame if you know you woke up
with concrete shoes
it'd be a shame if somebody investigated
your companies yeah and found some
infractions no instead they bought it
dave landau yeah exactly that is what
they do that is absolutely what they do
what's the there's this other site for
lots of money yeah for a lot so here's
here's a silver line you guys can go and
support them it's uh give send go hold
on give send go they've already uh uh
raised 4.3 million dollars that's
fantastic if you want to go we have the
link give send go
um for me screw this gofundme for this
convoy yeah never ever use them again
don't ever send them any money again if
anybody wants some money from you find a
different way um we're running late here
today so let's tomorrow we'll talk about
buying any silly comments about uh the
firearms but look i think was he wrong
again yeah he was wrong again um i think
he thought it was a flashlight
sorry
we really you know what look you can't
just go by uh by you know rallies like
donald trump would do but there's a
level of enthusiasm i mean dave just
right you were the well i brought the
highest selling white comic ever at the
denver white i just found out yeah
that's racist why would you why would
you even have that category well the
point is black comics are generally
better so it's graded on a curve yeah
it's true and they tend to support their
own people so they draw very well in
comedy absolutely it's absolutely true i
mean have you seen tyler perry's
pocketbook that's true he does a great
meditation the guy makes a billion
dollars in medea too he doesn't even
need the chinese market it's media's
media's pocketbook yes it is media's
pocketbook his wallet's pretty madea has
the same purse as brian stelter
oh my lord now i think uh
this is it well people have misused the
term cancel culture uh
i don't want to say that i just people
have gotten tired of the term cancer
culture let's let's stop using the term
canceled culture what i'm talking about
is people attempting to remove your
ability
to make a living this is an attempt to
ruin to destroy lives that's really what
it is cancer culture people oh you're
not canceled if you're still on spotify
no look they're trying to ruin joe
rogan's life
privately
through things that he said on a public
platform by the way in the open
they're trying to destroy your life
privately they're trying to remove
in canada all of this there's a through
line
them not allowing gas to get to these
truckers is the exact same as
the government saying spotify you need
to do more to throttle joe rogan it's
the exact same as them creating the
crowder rule over at youtube for
borderline content and senator hirono
saying why didn't they remove this
person it's all
a symptom of the same problem
and it's no longer about the free market
versus the government i understand that
at one point people would say well look
if you don't like that restaurant don't
shop there if you don't like this show
don't watch it sure got it but the
government wasn't saying
yeah but this shop this market's going
to be allowed this market we're going to
allow only tom thumbs we're going to
make sure that kroger is subject to
separate regulations that would be what
we're dealing with right now they didn't
used to say you know what we're going to
make sure that uh every single uh
television can get a b c but they can't
get nbc back when there are only three
stations now we have that actually
imagine if the government did that
but the government has come out now and
said you know what one america news is
misinformation and guess what they're
dropped from cable providers imagine if
they had done that with nbc think that
would have changed the landscape for abc
and cbs and by the way what kind of
messaging do you think would come from
abc or cbs i had to watch this in canada
i'll leave you with this and then we're
going to play they don't make them like
they used to on mud club there's no way
we could play that here on youtube
um in canada i don't remember the exact
numbers
but i know i'm close so i'll make sure
afterwards that we have these numbers
and the references available they were
they were campaigning for uh canadian
prime minister this is before trudeau
prime minister blackface made it in and
i believe if i'm not mistaken someone
from the ndp said that if they won they
would give like a hundred million
dollars or maybe with 75 million but a
huge sum of money to the cbc for
americans when what's the cbc it's the
only news effectively that we had in
canada when i was growing up it's the
canadian broadcasting corporation so a
candidate
who's running for office was saying if i
win
you're going to get more money how do
you think they're going to cover them
but then trudeau came in and i think if
the other person said 75 million or 100
million trudeau added like 50 and he
said i'll give 150 million to cbc oh boy
who do you think got the favorable
coverage
that's the issue when these networks
when these powerful companies believe
that they can get not only favorable
financial incentives but treatment and
an uneven playing field of course
they're going to do the bidding because
it's not just about money it's about
power and the power enables you to make
more money spotify facebook twitter
google youtube now we see gofundme you
can add a patreon to that list
if they know that the government has
their eye on them and that the
government will give them a leg up and
eliminate their competition as we've
seen or at least
call for it give them the support
publicly guess what they're going to be
emboldened and they're only going to be
emboldened to do the bidding of the
government all the all the bernie bros
out there all the people who are
liberals who can complain about campaign
finance you complain about citizens
united who don't fully understand what
citizens united was about and you
complain about corporatism
where are you on this
where are you on this
talk there's no more clear example of
crony capitalism outside of maybe the
big bank bailouts
which i know you guys think was
necessary too big to fail just like
elizabeth warren right with blackrock
where are you on this does this not
scare you where's where are the code
pinks
were the people who were against the
patriot act when george bush was
president
this is so much worse this is so much
more of an abusive power it's
unprecedented in american history and if
you go along with it or if you apologize
to these people you are apologizing to
evil because people who do not have a
heart for forgiveness the bible talks
about that those are evil people smash
that like button if you're watching here
on youtube right now it helps with the
algorithm comment below do you apologize
even if you think you're wrong i think
you know where i line up
and uh we're going to play they don't
make them like they used to so youtube
you know what thank you but not really
piss off
[Music]
you